on est tous tous tous touche jusqu'aux
je parle fâché avec quelqu'un très fort
il au temps passé qui fait qu'on ait
pris dans notre vie de notre routine
dans l'économie dans la boîte et le
temps passe et on n'y pense pas et
maintenant qu'on a beaucoup de temps je
pense qu'on pourrait tous se réconcilier
avec une moi j'essaie de koch pas si je
vais bien mais de match pas très
conseillé quelqu'un on va le faire
toujours 5-0 ce mois ci s'arrête une
séquence à deux mois tu vas te
réconcilier quelqu'un après deux mois je
vais vous les conseillez quelqu'un et
gilles doit aller bas mais voilà avec
des personnes très amoureux si c'était
moi je vous le dis franchement ça serait
mon père mais par exemple on se bat
depuis plus deux ans non c'est vrai mais
tous mais tu l'as eu tu l'as bien ces
petits salons mais ça arrive tu es un
tulle parle d'un micro chérie tu l'as eu
ton papa la peau depuis la cua depuis
depuis la crise on est fâché je n'ai pas
pris de nouvelle non non maintenant
franchement là ça dépasse la fâcherie
mathieu norma que frangins boucherit
sais que je t'aime énormément c'est vrai
ça m'a franchement ah ouais je veux que
tu appelles ton pas pourquoi mais même
hors antenne tu veux voilà je m'en fous
un mais je le ferai on est très attaché
depuis deux ans et cpnt est toujours
qu'avec le temps qui passe bas en fait
la réconciliation ça sera un jour sur un
lit d'hôpital et son indiscrétion
pourquoi tu t'es pas chèques n'ont pas
passé la côte d'ivoire sait que c'est
compliqué moi je peux rien mais a
longtemps et puis c'est c'est pour des
histoires de famille de bêtises de et il
a un caractère c'est un peu toi et moi
il a son caractère moi aussi puis
l'orgueilleux parce que c'est mon père
et puis moi aussi et on a enchaîné les
tours 2 en tulle m mais évidemment et
puis vieilli là il a un certain âge et
put a qu'une trouille sais qu'un jour tu
es un coup de téléphone qui est enfin
voilà le temps passe c'est comme on dit
quand on commence à viviez en général
les réunions de famille c'est toujours
lors d'un internement d'autant normand
houde envie d'aller vélo tu as envie de
l'appeler tu envie de prendre ces
nouvelles ou tu t'en en kecka quand tu
es seul chez toi comme je le suis et
comme beaucoup de gens de chez lui quand
tu es seul chez toi que tu fais un peu
le point et tu te rends compte que tout
d'un coup bas tu parles plus argent tu
parles plus ta boîte parce que tu as
peur mais ta boîte tu parle plus de
rupture et de tout ce qui est futile et
que tu te concentres sur vraiment
l'essentiel
bah tu te rends compte que l'essentiel
c'est comme la famille les gens que tu
aimes et là tu te dis effectivement j'ai
peut être raté quelque chose oui je
pense que ça devrait j'espère que ça le
fera réfléchir autant que ça me fait
réfléchir
tu as tu va l'appeler je pense
d'attentats temps qui t'appelle où tu va
l'appeler toi ça toi de la pluie je te
le dis ça toi d'appeler ton papa
pourquoi ben tu vas y résonne comme toi
une part du principe que je le suis donc
ça va devenir mardi à temps il ya déjà
il ya un respect de l'âge mais voilà
c'est toujours aux plus jeunes
mine de rien d'appeler puis sait-on pape
s'est trompé
ton père tu dois l'appeler c'est ton
père tu dois tu doit pas rester surtout
dans une situation comme celle-là je
vous dis et je le dis à tous ceux qui
nous regardent
franchement là on doit être tous
ensemble on doit être main dans la main
on doit tous se voient là et je veux
plus lent des plus dans un bain dans un
dose de on est fâché on n'est pas fâchés
on est tous ensemble pour essayer de
s'en sortir mon chéri ton papa a
franchement si demain tu apprends une
mauvaise nouvelle
ton papa et si demain même imagine on
sait pas ce qu'il peut arriver
tu peux plus le voir parce que voilà
aujourd'hui par exemple tu vois tu
voudrais aller voir ton papa et ben tu
pourrais pas parce que voilà tu été
confinés tu peux pas tu te rends compte
mine de rien même si on s'entendait bien
je pense que je devrais être confiné
avec ma famille chez eux et dans mon
normandie mais je suis pas si ton père
est tout seul ou pas il est avec sa
femme
d'accord il avec sa femme mais ils
travaillent plus aujourd'hui et c'est
vrai que ça fait exactement oui je pense
deux ans et demi qu'on sait pas vassale
parole si tu as un truc à lui dire c'est
quoi j'ai vu l'autre jour qu'il allait
qu'un petit un petit poste que j'ai mis
c'est un petit geste assez génial comme
ces jerash m'en viens site à site avale
un truc à lui dire ce serait quoi ça
serait quoi on regarde pas et je pense
qu'il a jamais regardé ce que je fais
mais ce serait oui ça serait que le le
le le temps passe le temps passe le
temps passe ce sera trappe pas et que
est que ben à des situations comme
aujourd'hui nous rappelle qu' on peut
tout on peut tout perdre si de toi moi
et que bien sûr tout d'un coup et des
maladies comme ça on peut tout perdre et
que c'est vrai que c'est cette période
là nous rappelle un souvent à quel point
finalement les très seule et de à quel
point tout ce qu'on fait dans la vie je
sais plus quel médecin disait une belle
voiture un machin c'est des
antidépresseurs pour ich tout ce qu'on
fait dans la vie en cours après une
société après après l'argent après
machin oui tout ça c'est cesser ces
futiles et on en oublie avec les
journées qui passe l'essentiel et je
reconnais que l'essentiel c'est de
famille il me reste ma soeur mais que
ouais si j'avais un truc à lui dire en
tout cas c'est que c'est que
bah qu'il fasse un petit geste je le
ferai aussi un intrus grâce à actu
passage est devant on en reparlera
demain mon mathieu mais demain on a tous
quelqu'un en comme ça d'ailleurs tu vas
faire un geste
toi tu veux te dire moi voilà moi tu vas
faire un geste on y tient et gilles
aussi tiens lui maintenant on en
reparlera demain mon chéri c'est que on
t'aime fort et je suis sur ton papa il
t'aime fort et qu'il est fier de toi
comme nom des fier de toi ici mais je
suis fier de toi
et en ce moment je trouve que tu as un
comportement exceptionnel voilà moi je
suis fier de travailler avec toi je suis
fier de ce que tu fais à l'antenne et
hors antenne et je te le dis ce soir
ben voila je te le dis était vraiment
malade et un caractère de canard
ouais mais tu es quand même mon ami es
tu resteras mon ami je te le dis si
c'est comme ça tous les deux parfois on
peut s'engueuler tu sais qu'on s'aime
mais voilà mais on tue c'est que je te
laisse jamais je sais que toi aussi tu
me l'as jamais voilà et ça c'est le plus
important